SPEAKER: Last time,
we covered how
you can use service level
indicators to measure
the reliability of
your services and how
to use service level objectives
to set reliability targets.
But what metrics should you
use to accurately measure
your reliability?
Today I'm going to show you how
to use out-of-the-box platform
metrics in Google
Cloud to do just that.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
[MUSICAL INTRO]
Let's start by
remembering that you
want to be able to
express your service level
indicators, or SLIs, as
ratios or percentages.
This allows you to normalize
various measures of reliability
and set reliability
targets in a uniform way
across your services.
Generally, SLIs fall
into two categories.
Request-based SLIs
measure the fraction
of good units of work
against the total.
For example, what percentage
of requests to an HTTP endpoint
were successful in
a given time window?
Window-based SLIs measure the
fraction of time intervals
during which the service meets
a threshold of reliability
over a given time window.
Now that you know
what you're after,
which metric should you use?
Do you just start writing
custom telemetry to create them?
Now there may be scenarios
where that makes sense.
And we'll cover those
later in the series.
But let's start with metrics
that Google Cloud Services
create for you right
out of the box.
Let's start with a
specific example.
Here's a common architecture
for a web application
that uses a global load
balancer to distribute traffic
to multiple GKE clusters.
For this example, you
can use these metrics
created by the global load
balancer for both availability
and latency SLIs.
Let's have a look
at how you can use
service monitoring in the
Cloud operations suite
to define a service and set
an availability SLO for it.
From the project dashboard,
let's go to the monitoring menu
and select services.
There are a number of
services already created
in this project.
Let's create a new one.
We'll use a GKE deployment
as the basis for our service
definition.
Let's name our
service and submit.
Now that the service
has been created,
let's define an
availability SLO for it.
The first step is to set
the SLI, or service level
indicator.
Services defined by App
Engine, STO, or Anthos
recognize availability and
latency SLIs automatically.
But we've defined
a custom service.
So we have to select
other as the metric.
We then need to decide
whether our SLI should be
request-based or windows-based.
We'll link to another
video that describes
the difference between
two in the episode notes.
But for now, we'll simply
calculate a proportion of good
to total events using
a request-based SLI.
The next step is to
select the metric
that we want to use as our SLI.
Because the service is being
provided by an external load
balancer, we can use the
request count metric.
We'll count all requests
in the total filter
and just those that return
a 200 in the good filter.
Note that this
approach does include
potentially erroneous requests,
like those that return 404s,
in the total filter.
And you should carefully
consider whether that's
the behavior you want.
Once we've made our
selections here,
we can evaluate
the resulting graph
to determine whether the SLI
will be properly evaluated.
Next, we'll select the
compliance period for the SLO.
We want the evaluation
period to be
long enough that
we can meaningfully
evaluate and allocate error
budget toward engineering work,
but not so long that
the error budget takes
too long to recover
from an incident.
We also recommend
using rolling windows
for operational
concerns rather than
calendar to avoid issues with
uneven numbers of weekends,
for example.
If you're just getting started,
a 28-day rolling window
is great.
Note that this is not
the alerting window.
We'll cover alerting in
SLOs in a future episode.
Now let's set a performance
goal for our SLO,
evaluate the SLI against
the goal over the last hour,
and click Continue to
finalize our setup.
Let's name our SLO
in a way that will
allow us to easily determine
what it's measuring
and create it.
Immediately, we can
see that we're actually
in the negative for error budget
for this particular service.
This is because we're
using a rolling period,
so the service is evaluated
over the last 28 days.
This is a new service.
And we simply haven't
had enough good traffic
to the service to recover
all of the error budget.
This will change as our service
serves more and more traffic.
So that's how you can use
service monitoring in Cloud
operations to define a custom
service and set an availability
SLO for it using an
out-of-the-box platform metric.
If you have a request response
service that uses Cloud load
balancers, using metrics
like request count
is a great way to easily
define an availability SLI
and set a target using an SLO.
But what about a data
processing pipeline?
In this example,
you want to monitor
how long it takes for
data flow to process
data elements in the pipeline.
This is sometimes called
a data freshness SLI.
Data flow captures this
information as two metrics.
System lag measures how
long it takes the entire job
to process messages.
Per stage system lag
measures how long
it takes for a given step in the
pipeline to process messages.
Because our service
isn't running in a GKE,
we'll have to create
a custom service
definition using the API.
Make a request to the services
endpoint in your project,
providing the service
ID and display name.
Once the service is defined,
you can create an SLO for it.
You can use the
system lag metric
that measures how long it takes
the job to process messages
as an indicator of freshness.
Let's have a look at how to
do that in service monitoring.
This time, let's start directly
on the services overview
screen.
Our data pipeline service
doesn't have any SLOs.
Let's create one now.
Because this is a custom
service which does not
support default availability
and latency metrics,
we'll use other as
the metric type.
Next, we'll select a
windows-based evaluation type.
The system lag metric
measures how long
it takes data elements to
make it through our pipeline.
This metric isn't
tracked per element.
So we don't have a way to
count a ratio of good events
to total.
So we'll need to use a
windows-based SLI, where we'll
track its average
over smaller windows
and count the ratio of those
windows that meet our threshold
over our evaluation period.
Let's select the metric and
specify our window criteria.
Based on the historical
data shown here,
we can expect the average system
lag to be under two seconds.
A five-minute window is
a great place to start.
Note that shorter windows will
be more responsive to changes,
but could also result
in a noisier signal.
Now that we've configured our
SLI, let's define our SLO.
We'll again use a 28-day rolling
period and set a target of 99%.
This means that we expect 99%
of our five-minute windows
over a 28-day period to
have an average system
lag of under two seconds.
Let's give our SLO
a good name and see
how our service is performing.
We can now see how
our SLI has been
performing against our
target and how much
error budget remains.
And that's how you can set
up a data freshness SLI
for a streaming data pipeline.
You've now seen how to
use platform metrics
to define SLIs and
SLOs for services
that use load balancers,
and for data pipelines.
But what about cases where none
out-of-the-box metrics work
for you?
One option that might is
to use logs-based metrics.
Let's have a look
at how to do that
using Cloud logging, Cloud
monitoring, and service
monitoring.
Here's a service that emits
a log entry for every request
that includes a status code.
Successful responses
include a 200 status code,
server errors include a 500
error status, and so on.
From these log
entries, we can create
a logs-based metric that will
count the number of requests.
The status label will allow us
to track successful requests
separately from failed ones.
We can view the metric
in Metrics Explorer
to confirm that it's
working as we expect.
We're now ready to configure
the SLI for our service
from this metric and
set an SLO for it.
Let's go to our services
overview, select our service,
and create an SLO for it.
Because we're essentially
using a custom metric,
let's select other
as the metric type.
We'll create a
request-based SLI,
because well want
it to calculate
a ratio of successful
requests to all requests.
Let's select our metric
to be used as the SLI.
We'll count the total
number of requests
by using the unfiltered metric.
We'll count the number
of good requests
by only counting those
that return a 200.
Let's have our SLO evaluated
over a rolling 28-day period
with a target of 95%.
Now we can see how
our SLI is performing
against our availability
target and how much
error budget we have remaining
in this evaluation period.
And that's how you create
an SLI and SLO using
logs-based metrics.
Thanks for joining me today.
In this episode,
we looked at how
to use platform metrics to
define service level indicators
and set service level
objectives against those.
We covered using
load balancer metrics
for request-response services,
data flow metrics for data
processing pipelines, and
logs-based metrics for services
that may not emit good
SLIs out of the box.
You're now ready
to start defining
SLIs for your own services.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSICAL OUTRO]